do you know any people I think here
should quit their job take another job
that pays them left summer home go rent
an apartment that shittier because
nobody walks outside work yeah
so my own lesson in the part about being
a TV up in the office - rabbit rabbit
wolfish the corporation talk about
ownership and average 1800 sectors and
output average
Australia yes we're doing it to the
Melbourne Cup yeah is there big horse
race a hundred shuts down and then if
you have a daughter laughing and I did
do that we'll leave yeah we will not we
will lose you give you a hundred percent
I go to again see if this place it was
good I'm instead AJ have a favor let BJ
& baby well sure yeah yeah I'm good
certainly decipher it but um you know I
mean when you only get two hours of
popular sleep but like real quick I've
got all of you I sleep six to seven
hours it's not how much I sleep it's
what I do when I'm awake I just want to
say it over and over because so many
people like Jim usually I [ __ ] sleep
laughs I didn't say um because obviously
the amazing news with AJ and then I
don't wake up so early to get to Atlanta
but yeah when I don't sleep I better do
you know it's crazy I already have the
natural like dark eyes I got and we had
that and then and then I just like so
Tommy now yeah I'm just like you know
and once I get done you know saying it
looks terrible when you works when you
hustle party people hang out with people
I mean there's nothing I like more than
what I'm about to do as much as I love
learning business as much as I love you
know everything that feeling is insane
there will be more about how I got to
that place of being the co-owner of the
agency like more of like like like why
are you sitting here like that like it's
all about work ethic really sorry
instead of something that is showing so
many people so many people that I use
motivation I get home sports I get it
for hip-hop I get a lot of places but
people get it like you gotta be careful
of not making it the only yoga all right
Rob don't go now we also know your way
to go it looking
I'm crazy flexion Alex winter isn't one
of them no knowledge of common elements
specializing they have a great card off
any matrix anymore yeah Nelson love that
I love this guy yes please tell him
please once a fall for my bikini we said
please set the record straight when
people please help everybody understand
what I really navigated through can you
can you fill them it was six months left
and five months of a bunch of people
that shouldn't be together together at
one time you said I'm a 301 right now
that's a lot of time on the whole school
surfeit how is there be a gym in desert
to be to be in society yet they were
adorable
Mickey I'm calculus oh just the
diminishing business point see I don't
think in her street AHA got Adam out of
college I got postcard in the mail and I
filled it out
March of my senior years like what are
we doing with college
I'm like mom what are we doing College
you knew that the process starts
sophomore year of high school she looks
at me she was you're gonna [ __ ]
college and let me [ __ ] no energy yeah
you know no moose please tell my friend
Chris here how many what percentage of
the kids on that campus you think
spent time in jail start with that
number in life
yes characters they shouldn't movies are
there there really shouldn't have no
Christmas only literally from the first
day you want to talk about chemistry
first day of college I walk in eighth I
went in three days late because they had
ice cream sauce all and all the crap so
I didn't my dorm room thing I look at my
bag this guy's laid off and if I woke up
and at that time I wasn't the happiest
person try to go to school be cool baby
you know and that B does not understand
his innate black kid like rapper like
has a bat right like like a slick what
if we be baculum Jerry when we're saying
God's whisper because it did nothing
deny everything we doing make
counter-accusations yeah listen that's
fine except this is a school word of
personal stab you like it wasn't like
this is not Virginia like this is I'm
saying I think take it ar-15 are one
thing dr. Spence cool how many pounds of
weed yeah
and rude understand that answer like me
I'm talking about like I had an ounce on
me
here's four pounds of weed buzzing it's
four pounds of weeks what else in your
room I'm sitting in a room playing some
Star Wars on children yes the possum
coming I don't like I'd I will tell you
I never did a single piece of drugs in
my entire life
these guys would sit over like this
[ __ ] smoke 21 through the head
it's never later never there was no over
under the radio we got the name is Joost
I got out Tom's came in we were doing
crazy [ __ ] more like we're putting 30
packs of Bud Light for the wind we were
doing so much trip but like but
everybody did that the extra elements of
the 54 some of the kids or the jam their
lives that's a different element like
most people went to college with nobody
they know went to jail like they don't
know a single person and me yeah I'm
feeling with the jail for battery
burglarly attempted person can go to
jail for DUI
what doesn't play it's a real story
and you do roll time and to the guys
over very much and one night I tell the
rest of the one night one make that came
to like daddy thank you and what he did
I wouldn't argue yeah and what do you
think I was gonna do defend my dad here
on jordin Mike and I forget about [ __ ]
even if I was initiate there was nothing
there was nothing I was doing to do that
yeah that's that you were monster good
packs uh-huh and uh yeah there were some
Universal we played a football game the
first of all really ridiculous we became
this pack 301 right we were in this
storm and we walked around school on the
gutters hit the second day about normal
script to Lucia's point first few days
on a secondary Normal School and we're
walking like 15 guys deep I'm more like
rural cruel
but that less right mm maybe 3000 anyway
we're walking along walk in the
cafeteria like 301 like really
ridiculous right but like other people
didn't like it so what did that lead to
we had on a football game to set up this
cooler when I tell you the entire school
knew about this game when to watch this
organized game of Malloy Hall versus
Brown haw right so we play the game is
the best toy we're playing all right
early on somebody got hurt or done how
it ended yeah anyways that's what one
looks like
I coping for a play I didn't think it
might have been you know like don't [ __ ]
up first play I get it interception
first play cool
we don't do it nobody's moving the ball
because [ __ ] quarterbacks we did not
have and people just getting with Glenn
with our boy was a quarterback big
intros nonetheless second series I get a
pick and I get open space and I'm like
going problem is as you can probably
tell every kid on the field was faster
than me so even though I had open space
this kid they're they're running that
caught me I would have scored but he
caught me pretty easily a good 20 hurts
from the end zone and even though it
should have been clean touchdown I but
I'm hyped so he tackles me and I'm
pumped and I blow like the football I am
like it you know like I'm excited he you
know this is now tied I didn't like that
before he even like got seized up to
like for us to fight I look back every
single person in my crew is on the field
running to fight and hit and his
roommate Iraq has a back
mentally we I forgot about this we talk
about example we know here's the back
yeah oh really funny because of the way
I got yeah this is a this is a feel of
the generous and I'm the only person
that actually said of the game reverse
discrimination Chris when I tell you why
I tell you if I was doing a daily vlog
Macklin
it would be the greatest problem yeah I
think in a rename it or being wrong a
hundred percent that was that football
game of all time most of you know what's
crazy most of our stories are from that
first semester of freshman year it was
that impactful dorms are right next to
each other like our rooms within this
quad right next to each other and at
like 11:30 p.m. every night when
everybody would like wine down go hook
up go to sleep go smoke whatever they we
do me and moose would go into his room
and play seven game series of NBA Live
seven game series every night battle can
say all that hey yeah I'm like are you
gonna take this off for 45 minutes
you did yeah ready now Matt I'm gonna
kill myself a cure
one thing that I really like it because
I thought that was go genius Thank You
[Applause]
Lana we believe and I love it always a
little like Balaam in that 10% but I
genuinely that 90% of this law is
spending way too much time trying to fix
the sink when the well is broken you're
good if life's awesome if you make
enough money if you like your work-life
balance if you like the people around it
if you're good you can take everything
that I have to say with a great result
and what I prove to the phone I'm in the
first state of our universe and the
access you have to reach anybody to sell
anything you want to do what you want to
do entrepreneurship I'm looking around
the audience centers people that
remember 1994 entrepreneurship wasn't we
nothing most people without existed ten
years ago
there's no Bossier Facebook page in the
DC consumption the only reason I loved
the process so much as I was hungry and
ambitious but what got me through my
twenties or thirties was I didn't give a
[ __ ] about what anybody thought about I
have Bureau to no tolerance and or
interest to seduce you and make you feel
good of converting later because I just
want you to work 15 hours a day if he
ambitions coming out of your mouth map
to work in this case again are
ruthlessly is bringing will get that map
to the ambition that is coming out of
your mouth that's it
that's number one we're even so many
people at first don't like me is because
I don't want anything from you
I want to put you in one place if you
can wrap your head around what's going
to happen over the next ten years how
many here are retiring in the next ten
years and 40 raise your hands I don't
mean that you're going to figure it out
I brush it and become a trillion or I
mean you're [ __ ] old and you're
finished when we're talking what am I
trying to accomplish how do I believe
that we the people that pay the price
blogging travel it's like how do I
deliver right now let me help you if you
are the type of person that stays
leading by five books and my videos that
stays sending their money to travel the
earth and see people talk that stays in
the point of consuming and being
motivated you will never succeed
people I think you should quit their job
take another job that pays them left
summer home go rent an apartment that
shittier and pick some time that they
get from having it - let me grab a
junior to learn the stuff and I actually
believe that is the fundamental model
for Africa
nobody's doing it because nobody walks
outside we're gonna roll up in the park
man
nobody does that that nobody's like are
you City apartment used to have a house
not happening you're going nowhere if
you're looking backwards you a 0%
interest and usually what I do i do my
blog and you watch it
that is not propaganda for you to work
15 hours a day that's just to make sure
that you realize if you want this it's
15 [ __ ] hours a day see
[Applause]
ah
season truth is always believed I love
them that person are cooking so let's
see what they do at that make sure you
get out by one okay what is your about
your effort you know that's like what's
so amazing first of all thank you for
asking that question
because that's going to help so many
people it's you're going to have to make
or that person is going to have to make
the decision on how aggressive they're
going to be with the conversation that
needs to happen which is you have to
create boundaries on lack of support is
suffocating and very difficult and so
look I I know especially grandparents
and parents generations of mine like 60
70 80 they ate everything right they ate
everything for I do forever I think the
reason we see higher divorce rates than
ever is because people want to be
happier I don't have the audacity to
give you the the anything but the truth
which is it should be a non debatable
issue that if somebody that you're
spending the rest of your life with is
willing to bring you down you've got
macro issues in the driver's license
consumer can express support for the
normal public attacker
yes I wish you I said we didn't buy
sauna I've never stopped of number of
jail on only cellulation
the process is the Roses the roses even
selling the companies the roses isn't
the new house the roses isn't the cover
of Entrepreneur Magazine the process is
a little bit yeah if you were interested
it's all over there
I would follow every one of them on
Instagram and Twitter and figure out
what they care about because if you want
to sell me something if you start
talking to me about the Knicks biggie or
the Jets you have a better chance right
so old-school sales the reason people go
and play golf and go to state dinners is
to get to know the person better to
actually make the sale social following
of those people allows you to know who
they are beforehand number 2 LinkedIn at
against the professions and then make
content that brings them value that's
not a sales pitch but that's something
that may be information for them that
makes their lives better a lot of but it
could be audio video a written word
everybody here who's making content
needs to figure out a federal writer a
video communicator or an audio
communicator on all three because I
built the infrastructure around myself
because I can't write but I can do video
and audio so yes blog ish if you feel
stronger in your writing skills but yes
video if you feel better in your video
skills follow people that you're trying
to sell to to figure out if they like
fishing if they like watching a TV show
or if they have four and a half kids I
like the lyrics another four or five
chips keep going open you can always go
back those suck [ __ ] for three years
never leave any and go what this and go
back to the phone dude you're welcome
because you know what's cool about as
well off its go something completely
different when you go back to this
nobody brings Michael Jordan for sucking
at baseball that's a good first another
senator Xerox got it okay good okay
what's happening everything that I can
grab with the money make the world go
round
Queen run Rick classic with reality TV
give it the kids to where they flaws out
on page P don't try to play me
high-stakes very call crazy I haven't
done oh my god father eighty Rachel baby
whooping English speaker box it's cold
when your system of blow make it hot
come in on the dropping afford your dis
became packing no fool stay with a
history here spring cleaning
I've been all try for the rabbit out the
Hat and I am a man of jail day with that
bumper missile project with the visor
multi my little pistol grip pop what you
all hate everything you need but the
media Ottawa to speak of free
[Music]
[Music]
it's our belief and Scott thank you guys
come on already
we are like human social interaction but
keep scrolling roller door I'm watching
their eyes begin to live huh keep the TV
on for background noise and keep paying
the table I have no choice we using so
we don't gotta think and there's a lot
of things wrong in this world we got
upsot insane the rat race has got us
live in half a - the bad days front of
the face you can't shake feeling good
about that a little talk a bunch of
business stuff the British kind of like
can also we see everybody getting into
the 4th of July mindset tomorrow
probably be slow the internation hope
you don't sue / well thanks for being
part of this journey
hope you're getting value out of it keep
hitting me up on Twitter I've gotten a
gotten an enormous amount of interaction
there and continue to enjoy that and
there's no question the place to get me
so keep doing that
and that you should work for supporting
the podcast employment yet means a lot
to me and Big Ups to everybody who's
come to the four DS did that yesterday
that's the internal vaynermedia
consulting product that we do for a day
Manor for today they're going to go
Welland I love you you're doing a really
good job in I mean it like will always
forever have this we're in the vortex
now we're in the horse
[Music]